hey guys so I'm so excited it's actually
really early right now but when I post
this it won't be early but right now
it's real early so we're about to go on
Access Hollywood Live and this is the
set where's Brian at Brian you run for
my
camera surprise Billy in the makeup BR
no I'm nervous I'm nervous I can't do it
I'm nervous I can't I'm nervous I'm
nervous sorry I can do it I can't do
what I'm scared look when you get to be
my age your brows start blowing up like
Andy Rooney oh my God that's just
something you have to do I gave mine a
little trim this morning too it's a
process looks like somebody hauled a
brush and laid it on my face well I will
see you on the show I'll let you guys
get back to the trimming every two
weeks
K we just got on it was so much fun yeah
good job I'm beer pong or something at
8: a.m. or 9:00 a.m. I know so I heard
you're going to give me a behind the
scenes tour of the studio you ready
you're starting with wardrobe these are
the most important women in the world
and we love them that's Michelle and
that's Ashley and uh Nicole is the other
one she's Nicole there she is she's Nico
Hell she's lost so much weight she's
invisible look at this is my dressing
there's a star on the door just fit
stroke the you play hockey I did play
hockey when I was in uh in boarding
school that was a senior year do you
have a particular hockey team I'm a
penguins fan New York okay the that's
CRA dad is my bathroom and then I don't
use it really that's good it's cold in
my room it's dark it is a little chilly
and if you really want to pee quickly
and easily in a commercial you do it in
a warm environment so what I do is I use
her bathroom hi hi we're doing a little
behind the scenes and I always go right
in here between commercials and
sometimes she can't even get in cuz I'm
and he doesn't put the seat up and he
sometimes yeah I'm going to work on that
yeah you can I'm going to work on that I
want
that There's No Business Like Show
Business there's no business I
know it's all here the guys right there
there's Billy does the lights Vic does
everything else beautiful Runway it's
just a great big play really great set
don't you like it I love it I want to
just kind of like move in well we want
you to come back and be a part of it and
eny so much fun you watch the show all
the time I Justine me Justine you
Justine it is it definitely is bye thank
[Music]
you